hello what hello and welcome to this
video playing fmd WG 6dw g6 from the UK
who is that as they're named David
Walker okay now I don't know this person
let's see I'm playing this line in the
cup of line against the in the English I
don't know it well I have to really
admit that but recently when I did
preparation against a player and in my
from one of my league games I found out
that he regularly own place that opening
with black it has fantastic results I
mean like like excellent yeah and I was
thinking okay maybe it's something that
I should look at um that I didn't but
i'll try it out a little bit at least it
feels very natural and to develop in
that in that style not like the Italian
game yeah okay I've got to destroyed at
the light squared Bishop and I wonder if
I can go for some f5 kind of business
and hmm 94 83 I wonder if I have some
kind of that's probably completely
Unseld 94 and then second f2 like a
three-night f2 matters and sound let's
not do this he's probably aiming for 95
so maybe get the night over Oh
interesting
and it's what I can take now and play a
five he's out for c5 though I I see can
go see five hmm anyway I have to play a
five otherwise I don't get any play it's
that's clear okay threatening Bishop e3
now but wyd will go now if you go see
five okay he doesn't react to my threat
why is that not going I think it works
so take it f takes Knight eggs wins the
Queen and it's a very important pawn the
porn that covers the default square
you've got g5 right c6 I'll wait wait
let let's let's let's not be let's be
cool here I can just take the rock first
before I do anything else I will take
his rook and then we'll see what happens
I go d5 next and c6 and that's it okay
that's as it was the cleanest way he has
to move the night back and I place is
six and he has no play whatsoever wait
resides yeah i was a bit lucky that he
overlooked Bishop e3 I mean okay lucky
is wrong word but it was a gift let them
interesting yeah I don't really believe
that it can be so great for what if he
just allows me to to trade that bishop I
don't know is that usual I'm I feel
pretty happy there but ok the other
computer gives an interesting line this
is maybe the reason why this is not so
great i mean 95 them
that makes an awful lot of sense I
cannot just go back I mean I can but
yeah not good doesn't look good so this
is probably what I have to do in quincy
seven-night f5 and this interesting now
I'm threatening some sacrifices their
the engine says equal interesting hmm ok
to e 1 cap III was under fire now the
compounds could be five they are very
ugly very idea so this happens yeah i
have d 5 but i wasn't sure about this so
just it looks good 97 yeah i was
thinking about this briefly but after
age three this didn't this didn't seem
too clear to me i was thinking it could
be interesting well the engine gives
equal so it wasn't completely completely
bonkers but fatherhood strange so let's
do this and now f5 I need counter player
I cannot play some some lame move and
now it went takes my cheeks and now an
ID for is just a blunder he I think he
probably has to do this which heats the
interesting plane this is the ones I
want to play with yes'm he's got c6
which isn't even that clear
because I still have that move cool well
I wouldn't I wouldn't care quite slap am
and this is coming that's kind of
interesting yeah he has to go see five
after see five white is probably
somewhat better my bishop 1a7 looks a
bit looks a bit stupid the computer
wants to play a waiting move or covering
move let's say and gives white 0.4 yeah
this is essentially losing its not just
a pawn for the materia count but also
then porn porn that guarded the g four
square this is the big problem jen geo
just take the rook and 25 now it just
has a night retreated NC sixes that you
see a smooth just keeps a totally sound
porn structure bloggers of corn and the
exchange of anti as an attack on the
king so that's a pretty easy win okay
thanks for watching